[Music]
where'd you come from the enterprise duh
beamed in you beamed in yeah I thought
you were a movie buff Star Trek
transporters i beamed in yeah familiar
with the terminology I'm also familiar
with the fact that Star Trek is science
fiction therefore not real so how did
you get here ooh
Star Trek is real all right saying keep
that back pony I forgot how much of a
tricky you are
it's trekker all right you know we like
to be referred to as trekkers okay I
don't have to take this go back to the
enterprise down all right you came here
to talk to me about something so what
was it saw Star Trek in the darkness I
thought you might want to talk about it
yeah you see it yeah I did it was
awesome what did you think it has some
pros and it has some cons you only find
the cons Star Trek so gotta give it pro
points just for being start right in the
first place I think you know it's not
real Star Trek
also this is the second Star Trek movie
in a row that's given us a hot chicken
or underwear well what's up with that
but it's awesome so that's another Pro
I'm still waiting to find what the con
is the villain and I didn't like the
villain and I won't worked come on
Benedict Cumberbatch I mean is the best
thing about this movie he was awesome I
thought he was terrible
come on I thought he was terrible that
huh I mean Star Trek villains are
supposed to be these big awesome famous
actors like no Carlmont of Honor
Christopher Lloyd got from Sound of
Music
but this time when we get his British
Sherlock Holmes dude Sherlock Holmes is
always British always not when it's
Robert Downey jr. not when it's Lucy Liu
how can you be
aware enough culturally to know that all
those people are in Sherlock Holmes
adaptations but not know that Sherlock
Holmes is British or that Lucy Lewis
playing in Watson how can you be that
dumb all I'm saying is I would have
preferred another actor I thought it was
awesome it was the best thing about the
film even people who ate this movie
you're gonna read about him Haman Kirk
you know locked in mortal combat well
it's not alike
to start with it's the Kirk and Spock
show this movie I mean yeah it was on
Scotty
Hurra check off bones
I miss those guys all of those people
are in this movie I didn't see him you
have a reputation for not looking hard
enough I have a reputation for paying
too much attention sometimes it does
make me miss some details so you say
they were in it and I'm willing to take
your word for it
it's kind of still surprised you liked
it as much as you did you shouldn't be
movies awesome dude it is action-packed
pants are action-packed and how am I
even supposed to be offended by that I
mean like what scenario can you think of
where that would be anything but a
compliment like if you had pants on to
an insult it makes it more insulting
even if it's a compliment whatever dude
smooth is awesome it's got action
romance bromance space everything I want
my start record
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa it is not your
star trek all right it's not anybody's
start directed right everybody's star
trek everyone I don't have it I didn't
need to take ownership of this movie so
awesome why isn't it like headlining the
Cannes Film Festival this week column
what it's calm not can no I'm pretty
sure it's can wrong pants maybe can s
but it's definitely not gone right
because you're the authority on how to
pronounce French words you know I could
call the enterprise any time I want and
have them be mew'd of freaking Mars
looked out in the middle of space why
don't you do that or better yet I could
use this phaser the Captain Pike gave me
and she view that the sea not a phaser
it's set to kill that is a set of hair
clippers no this is a phaser that it's
made to look like a set of clippers what
a difference this thing will kill you
let's see it
[Music]